this is like a Monumental moment for you
do you feel it yes
yes feel like
for one thing just seeing all those
people that are my absolute Heroes but
then you look at the clock and it says
30 seconds
your time is up
move it along
don't mess with me yeah she took her
time so I would say to you take your
time I'm still getting used to these
types of things so I'm you know I feel
like uh I got some things to learn from
people not only did you pay homage to
Elvis in your speech you did shout out
Denzel Washington people like that for
so long in my career I was I was doing
things that I was grateful for but it
wasn't it wasn't the lane that I wanted
to be in I wasn't working with the types
of people that you you know like my my
dreams of being with somebody like
Denzel and
doing this play that I did with with
Denzel on Broadway like that was the
thing that changed my career and then
from there getting to work with Quentin
Tarantino changed things as well and so
to see Quinton I mean Quentin and Brad
were the were the two people I saw right
before walking on stage and just
thinking about the fact that Denzel
didn't have to go out like he's the king
he doesn't have to do anything for me
but he took it out of the kindness of
his heart to call bazen I just um I
respect him so much and I'm so grateful
to him it just feels like this cherry on
top when you get a moment like this that
feels like uh something I've seen a lot
of my heroes get up there and do you
know it's it's really special
[Music]